this summer if romance comes it comes  not that it doesn't but I don't want to  hold back summer is a time to do  whatever you want this summer is going  to be legendary wherever we are as long  as we're together we're just going to do  everything music the energy the vibe  everyone's having fun  seeing all the homies talking it goes I  want to do everything is gonna be the  best summer  I'm so excited remember and having the  best time of your life this summer is  going to be so nice summer is a time to  have fun and do all the things you've  always wanted I'm gonna remember this  summer for the rest of my life to be a  non-stop party you just like having a  connection with another sensor this  summer is gonna be lazy summer break is